we're in the middle of the longest
streak of private-sector job creation in
history more than 14 million new jobs
the strongest two years of job growth
since the 1990s an unemployment rate cut
in half he's right the American economy
is climbing its way back from the
recession but something's happening to
the middle class it's shrinking how's
that possible let's look at the numbers
and we'll begin with median household
income which over the years has been
trailing behind US GDP growth even
falling in some periods that means that
while the US economy grows
not everyone's bank account grows with
it and if we go back to the 1970s those
considered middle-class households were
earning around $9,000 which have
adjusted to inflation is just over
$53,000 fast-forward to the past couple
of years middle-class households are
making only 50 1759 dollars that's 1942
dollars less in adjusted dollars overall
the number of Americans recorded as
middle-class shrunk from 61% of the
population in the 1970s to just under
50% now yes that's because some of the
population got richer but more folks
have become poorer too sure the prices
of gadgets like flat-screen TVs and
laptops are more affordable than ever
but college tuition child care health
care and housing costs are on the rise
the average cost of a house in the
United States has increased fivefold
since 1970 which is well over inflation
and childcare for two kids generally
costs even more than rent if we break it
down simply the price of a dozen
conventional eggs would cost four and a
half times more if it increased as fast
as college tuition has over the past
three decades so where is the share of
money going it's shifting to the top
earners upper-income households hold
half of the country's wealth but only
account for 3% of the population and get
this the 20 richest Americans have more
money than the bottom half of the
American population that's over 105
80 million people okay okay before you
completely lose all hope there is some
good news
median family income rose more from 2014
to 2015
than it had in 17 years 2015 also
brought the largest drop in national
poverty in 16 years and for the first
time ever more than 90% of Americans
finally of health insurance steps in the
right direction
yes but the 45th President of the United
States has a big task ahead